Speaker 1: So unfortunately, it's become
very toxic now to talk about what's going
on with Russia and Ukraine, and there's
almost no assertion that can be made
without someone popping up out of the woodwork
and saying, No, no, no, no. That's a tank talking
point or that's an imperialist talking point
or whatever. Even relatively uncontroversial
statements like Putin likes to play games with
his aggression. It's like, you know, who could
possibly deny something like that? But someone
is lying and there is some truth, and I don't
think we really know it. And unfortunately, what
has become very toxic about discussing the Russia
Ukraine story is that any claim triggers someone
into saying, you are playing a role for X, Y or Z
side or perspective or enclave
or whatever the case may be.
This gets us to the latest news, which is
well, on the one hand, we were told that
Vladimir Putin and Russia were pulling troops back
from the Ukrainian border. That would be a great
thing if it were true, making it less likely that
there is going to be an invasion. Unfortunately,
Naito and the U.S. and Ukraine and others
say not only is Russia not pulling back,
they seem to actually be building up troops even
further. Now someone is lying. Both can't be true.
And I guess theoretically, the way that you could
have sort of some technical truth to both would be
there has been some pullback in one area near
the Ukrainian border with a buildup elsewhere.
And then both sort of may be true. But the
spirit of it, of course, is like overall,
is Russia moving towards Ukraine or away from
it? There's a new Reuters report which says
West warns military buildup near Ukraine growing,
not shrinking. That's very direct and very clear.
Estonia says Russia likely to launch a limited
attack Russia releases video showing tanks
leaving Crimea, Ukraine Defense Ministry
hack worst of its kind, says government And
there's a question as to whether Russia
is responsible for that hack. There's a
growing Russian military presence at Ukraine's
borders, Western countries warned on Wednesday,
as Estonia said battle groups were moving ahead of
a likely attack to occupy key terrain contradicts
contradicting Moscow's insistence of a pullback.
More armored vehicles, helicopters and a field
hospital have been spotted. Britain's defense
intelligence chief said in rare public comments,
up to 7000 more troops have moved to the border in
recent days, including some arriving on Wednesday.
A senior official in Biden's administration said
without providing evidence. So there are people
who will say, We can't trust Biden, we can't
trust Naito. Anything they say simply cannot be
believed. They're just straight up lying.
Obviously, Putin is pulling back from Ukraine.
It doesn't seem obvious, and I think the other
part of this situation that's gotten difficult
and this is just it's if I sound bummed out,
it's because I and that this has now become
almost like a it's sort of like a Venezuela type
situation for some on the revolutionary left,
where there's this wing of the left that ends up
mean the right is totally gone. Cuckoo. I'm not
even addressing them right now, but there's
this wing of the left that ends up in their
desire to always oppose American imperialism and
American intelligence. They will end up supporting
and defaulting to believing authoritarian
strongmen around the world. And we saw this
with Venezuela, where if you say, Hey,
you know, the stated populist ideals of
Chavez and now Maduro are just window dressing
for authoritarianism and the pillaging of the
country's resources for the gain of the
elites. And on if you say that you're
wow, you're you're an American imperialist. No.
What did I say about wanting the U.S. involved
in any way? I said nothing about that, but that's
how you're branded. And unfortunately, if you say,
Hey, you know, Putin's intentions may not be
all on the up and up here. Similar allegations
fly. And unfortunately, or I don't, I don't
even know if it's a question of fortune. But
speaking realistically, we don't really
know Vladimir Putin's intentions here.
His intention may be to invade Ukraine.
His intention maybe not to invade Ukraine,
but to goad the West into doing something
which will give him a leg up in negotiating
position in the future. Putin's intention may be
to do this to rattle Western stock markets, which
it has been doing like if that were Putin's goal.
It has succeeded. I do not think we really know,
and what we do know from history is it's unclear
why anyone would believe Putin absent real solid
evidence. The video of tanks moving in one
direction. Doesn't really tell us definitively
what is going on. That video could be it could
be anything could have been filmed any time.
It quite literally is of no value whatsoever. And
we know that Trump believed Putin, right? Like
when Putin told Trump, we didn't hack anybody.
Trump immediately immediately came out and said,
Listen, I asked him, Did you hack us? And he was
very strong in his denial, and I believe him. OK,
well, so we know Trump believed Putin.
Most people don't believe Putin unless
they have independently verified the things that
Vladimir Putin is saying. So that's where we are.
One last thing from D.W. Naito fears Russia is
seeking pretext to attack Ukraine. That's another
idea, which is what Putin is doing is to cause
Ukraine to do something which will then justify
the invasion. And that's why we see the back
and forth. So we're not going to know. Maybe
for another day, maybe for another week, we don't
know. But anybody telling you this is the ultimate
and definitive truth on what Putin intends to do.
Be skeptical of that. Be skeptical of that because
we don't know. And anybody telling you, I mean,
it's a very Trumpian thing which will sometimes
hear from those on the revolutionary left. You say
I, you can only I know the real thing. Anything
else you're hearing can't be trusted. This is
the one definitive explanation and analysis.
Be skeptical of that. You will do. You will do
well to remain skeptical of those such claims.